they took everything from refrigerators
to washing machines two of my cars were
broken into and two were stolen they
turned on the head of the village with
assault rifles the head of the village
baked bread for us she wasn't obliged to
we did not leave the basement for four
months the rest of her life is not
enough to rebuild everything that we had
we thought that the Russians had
returned and then we saw there were guys
yeah people were all crying I can't talk
about it without tears there's no water
there's no light nothing but it became
easier to breathe that's it
[Music]
today we had some coffee and nikolaev
and plan to visit Carson but in the cafe
we met the commander of a very effective
unit
and she said that today his Fighters
will be delivering humanitarian Aid to
The Villages which nobody has visited
yet meaning there's no electricity no
water no connection no one has really
tried to reach these places
we'll be among the first ones and we
really want to talk with these people
ask them about what they experienced
we want to see everything with our own
eyes
[Music]
we're approaching the video fraud the
distance is short but we've been on the
road for more than two hours due to the
mining of the territories
so we have to go track to track
quite dangerous
but we see a lot of destroyed houses a
lot of soldiers the tension can be felt
because the battles are happening very
close we haven't seen civilian people
yet
[Music]
come on come on let's go to the Chicago
Street now that one yes what did they do
they made a mess everything that was
nobody's they took yes they took
everything that wasn't nobody's
everything we they say we don't know how
to walk we only know how to drive give
us cars amenities cause there's a
kindergarten there there were there cars
by which they came they were on the
hoods on the roofs they put on them
something like here they burned down a
house and another one over there they
bumped
my brother's house was set on fire on
the street the neighbors came out and
said how smoke is coming from the house
so I went there and put it out
until it should but they were often
assault rifles at people's
forehead they had no idea yet it was the
first ones that came in black uniforms
police whoever they were
while we were giving other people butter
or flour and they climbed over the high
fence at our house and dragged me
started to beat me on the legs
but an automatic rifle to my forehead
here they burnt the house they said that
they'd burned down the house they did
not know that I'm also military former
military
they burn this one through a grenade
completely burnt it people from the DNR
came to me and said we know that you
were in the anti-terrorist operation
then Russians came by car we know about
you and then I was at my brother's house
they arrived drunk and they they didn't
say that I was taking part in the
Russian Ukrainian war in the East only
that I was in self-defense I wasn't home
they shouted where's your son where is
the husband
be careful
foreign
[Music]
they came to us on the 6th of March the
very first Russian troops came on the
6th of March for four months we didn't
leave the basements we were constantly
in the basements we lived there it was a
horror it's just a horror
how did we live we were afraid to leave
the yard they looted they made a mess
our village head was threatened with an
assault rifle because some people
snitched on her what a we were
sitting in the cellars sleeping there
because we were afraid we were in the
cellars for half a year thanks to our
Administration head we were not hungry
here at first she tried to bring oil and
flour from another Village baking bread
for us the head she was baking bread she
wasn't obliged to she was making sure we
had water power as long as there was an
opportunity she was stopping there
beforehand they marched with assault
rifles disturbing everyone so she was
running around bare-handed fighting back
we told her that someone would kill her
someday God forbid but God's mercy they
did not kill her she took out her lard
and said don't go people don't go these
Orcs they were not humans they were Orcs
don't go around houses don't ask our
people for dude I will bring you my Lord
my Lord
I didn't go against assault rifles I ran
after them I drove they stole flower
from my bakery I caught up with their
cars and returned the flower to the
bakery how they came to people I
followed them brought them back because
it was not possible otherwise
I was afraid my husband fought in the
War in the East I was afraid he told me
we will be killed someday he said we
will be killed we survived everything
thank God
the people who stayed here helped each
other that's how it was and what did
they say to you when they were talking
with the locals were they saying
something they said that Russia would
stay here yes we're planning to reach
Odessa by the new year he said that
that's such a nonsense they purposefully
looted empty houses which people had
left they took everything from
refrigerators to washing machines to
women's underwear
smashed two of my cars and they stole
the other two foreign
they hit my son-in-law's Land Rover and
they destroyed the engines they drove
away then we took our cars back I
already took them from the garage and
from outside the village bro what can
you do with them if they if they're
armed with rifles they took away all my
weapons I had three guns and they took
them all when the last ones came they
were shooting up in the air in the
garden and they were shooting at our
feet they wanted to take the forklift
but they didn't give it to them thank
God that our army came soon and the
Russians left thus there were still some
untouched cars that were hidden we were
hiding everything we could yeah they
didn't take them all away I had two
zills and I had a milk truck I now
deliver water to people the truck was
hidden so it wasn't taken away they took
those trucks that stood on the street
but not the forklift because they didn't
have any time
Village HUD wasn't here
it was on the 15th of April yeah she
wasn't in the village at all then this
terrible looting began we ourselves
couldn't we couldn't do anything so we
were forced well I was looking around
for her waiting for her as she is a
representative of the government so
maybe she could do something they took
everything everything possible from
school from the library
yes yes the soldiers Russians
they took everything from the Village
Council yeah they broke into the Village
Council
they broke into the back door of the
Village Council and they started taking
everything out look imagine that even
brooms
they even took toilet paper from the
toilet it's just terrible it's just
terrible and they let you come back
after going to kriviri at that time it
was possible in April on the 15th of
April we arrived at six in the evening
from
yeah yeah the Russians already came to
my yard and accused me of exposing their
positions I thought that my husband and
I were screwed because of that yeah just
that day The Village was getting shelled
starting from the morning and they
blamed her that she allegedly left the
village and exposed the positions to the
Ukrainian Army and that's why they were
shelling The Village although she was
yet to reach our positions when the
village was already getting showed it
was seven in the morning and what did
they do to you after that they didn't do
anything they came to us three times and
interrogated us about the same their
positions that's all they didn't do
anything to us nothing the thing is that
we have few people here and
um how could we be partisans if many
people in the village were snitching no
way collaborators they were showing
which cars were owned by who we weren't
able to be partisans and what about
these people now this is a this is a
problem of the Secret Service of Ukraine
and we'll let them deal with it they
were beaten a little bit and they're
taking pictures of the of the signs of
beating and they're complaining they're
already hanging out with their arming
and they're trying to do well with our
guys when Ukrainian Army came here the
attitude of our guys it really was
ukrainians with whom you can talk with
whom you can we were all crying here
damn it
and those Russians don't understand
human language they don't understand the
relationship This Is How They are you
see they start telling you that here are
the guys from the front line those who
came a lot I'm with the guys they lived
opposite of me and lived in my house
they said that many of our people died
on the front lines a young man 19 years
old is walking in front of me
good day I'm 19. he's answered I said
why are you here I asked you know that
zelensky signed the law so if you
surrender you will be alive
you can't go there because they will rip
off your skin and cut off something yeah
they scared us the Ukrainian troops
they'll come and uh you know
they said such scary things to boys such
scary but we knew the truth the also
wanted to take us out they were coming
to houses and telling people to leave
the village they are strongly
threatening us to leave they said that
you'll be screwed here but where can I
go all my life I've been working to get
that tractor I work for that milk truck
and now where can I go if we leave now
him me he has equipment over there Utica
the farmer where would we return to if
everything was robbed if we came back
how would we continue to live my whole
life we'll need an entire life to earn
back what we had
how you greeted our army
the yard and got scared we thought that
the Russians returned
and then when we saw bizarre guys
our army was driving here on tanks and
we were waving at them we came to them
and we hugged everyone oh we were so
glad that our guys finally came
I was with the flag maybe you saw me on
the internet with a flag it was me they
said oh this woman is already on that
street that woman was running with the
flag it was me here the flag is still
hanging in the yard yeah I immediately
went out and I said oh God The Horde is
returning and sveta the neighbor shouted
no it's our guys I ran to get the flag
I'm screaming here the Georgians come
they come I ask oh God you're not gonna
kill me are you you can watch it on the
internet I'd say you're not gonna kill
me and they said no glory to Ukraine and
I answered glory glory to Heroes this
was posted on the internet I haven't
seen it yet that's it so we met them on
the first day here together with another
family we fed them because seven men
asked to everyone tried to greet them
like this and girls the neighbors met
the grandmother was standing there were
the neighbors they also met on the
street as we could we didn't know right
away that those were our guys coming
what was giving you the strength to hold
on and believe that our army would
return the hope that our guys will come
back to me for example God I believe
only in God God gave it to us we prayed
and our relatives prayed my daughter is
in Kiev so we were told wait until June
wait until July soon soon we were
awaiting month after month and they
finally came thank God what was giving
you the strength swayed for our military
well what gave us strengths they faith
in our soldiers probably
um first of all faith faith that they
won't leave us that we will still be
Ukraine not Russia we didn't want to be
Russia the Russians came yeah remove
your flag at the Village Council remove
and put up the Russian flag I told them
kill me shoot do what you want but I
will not put up the Russian flag and so
the Russian flag was not hoisted in our
village yes it didn't stay with us for a
single day yes not a day and how did you
celebrate when the Ukrainian Army came
and liberated you don't ask why not I
better not ask that
so you celebrated well very well my wife
still doesn't talk with me no she talks
but through her teeth
carefully of course people were all
crying to be honest crying a lot it's
hard to tell without tears to be honest
you came now and we went outside we
talked
communicate move but then we couldn't do
that back then my wife spent so many
months in the cellar until now you know
I called my daughter today she lives in
uh she lives in Carson she says dad
there's no water there's no light
there's nothing but it became much
easier to breathe that's how it is
thank you
[Music]
this man he was in Afghanistan went
through everything he saw everything in
our village
thanks to our guys they removed those
tanks that were standing here one of
them put it's muzzle in my window it was
destroyed and the second one was
destroyed near my close friend's house
the friend is also sitting there our
guys are still in the car so everything
is fine
who hasn't been through it hasn't seen
it imagine they come into your yard
what would you do I wasn't really afraid
they put the guns towards me I wasn't
afraid I wasn't afraid of death but they
didn't kill me they took away the cards
took away the barrel but I took it back
from them later the bombs are falling
over there and my mother is 87 years old
and on all fours I barely managed to put
her in the cellar I didn't have a seller
but we survived and we were driving
under the shelves loaded my mother and
drove away thanks to our soldiers we
left one of them was so tiny carrying an
assault rifle he claimed to take some
water if I hit him I would have killed
him they were walking like that
especially one day they came here took
one battery from the car the next day he
came again I need a battery listen I
said I'm sorry you took one away
yesterday like this with an assault
rifle I would have beaten him myself if
I touched him once I would have killed
him honestly wait my close friend's car
was taken all our lives we were earning
money all our lives we worked for
ourselves we worked on this land and
they came and took everything away what
could we do because there were many of
them and we had nothing
what could we do everyone tried to stay
because we had to live somewhere we were
left with nothing at all can you imagine
without a house without a farm I left my
daughter bought me we had nothing at all
my wife's brother helped gave something
we didn't take anything we just took the
documents and that's it we ran away
leave why don't you leave and where
should I go this is my land this is my
house here are my children my parents
why should I go somewhere and I have an
elderly left here in The Villages
thanks God and thanks to the army of
Ukraine
dear friends I have a trophy from
Chicago the partisan Heroes
who wants left from a grenade launcher
we'll keep it to remind us that the
Russian federations
thank you
[Music]
we're returning from Chicago there
right
we got here with the military who
brought humanitarian into the people
because almost nobody comes to them
there was only as I saw one car with
humanitarian aid for the whole community
and what can I tell you we talked a
little with people we listened to their
stories and in general no it's
everywhere Russians are Russians they
were stealing everything threatening
people throwing grenades into ordinary
houses just for fun
several houses were burned for no reason
um they quickly fled when our Armed
Forces began to advance
the last ones left us on the 8th of
November and the troops of the Armed
Forces of Ukraine entered it's correct
to say they ran away not left the
Ukrainian Army came on the 10th of
November at half past five in the
evening we were standing here and the
boys were walking there we thought the
Russians returned we ran back into the
yards we thought that this hell would
repeat and then we realized that they
were our guys we ran falling over to the
Village Council thanking our army
I say
we waited
we weren't ashamed to look into our
armies eyes
we didn't betray them we waited for them
and the most important thing is they
didn't leave us
we invited them to our houses I have
three of them living in my home
me too the first night when they came
out on the evening of the 10th of
November eight people spent the night at
my house
everything was fine we are very grateful
to them it was everything was Ukraine
and everything was fine very grateful
well we met with people who were really
cool really strong
and it was obvious that they were scared
but they weren't afraid to say what they
thought there was one cool woman that
had yeah the head of the village
um she said that in the first days some
information about her appeared in the
media well not in the media but like
somewhere on the internet that she was a
collaborator but all the locals said
that it's not true
they told us how she was helping every
day she did everything she could that
the community could live without
cooperating with the Russians they made
such key decisions collectively
terrible things about her it's terrible
things that she didn't deserve
you asked people not to take anything
from the Russians did they offer you
their humanitarian Aid they brought
humanitarian Aid I gathered my people
and our people decided we didn't have
any money we didn't have any groceries
and now people decided that they would
take humanitarian age that is why they
brought it to us I won't say that they
didn't take it because they did there
was simply no other way out
but she didn't leave she stayed to help
the people her husband fought in the
Russian Ukrainian war in the East since
2014.
um As I understood she was also taking
part in the war in Afghanistan but he
was defending Ukraine prior to the
full-scale invasion for sure and they
didn't want to speak for a long time
like they didn't want to tell us then
behind the scenes this man started
showing a video of
um broken Russian equipment on which she
directed Ukrainian artillery and um well
he handed over their positions to our
military and we thought there were no
partisans there but you know it turns
out that there are no former Ukrainian
soldiers people continue to serve even
under occupation
he was like very shy and in the end he
didn't really want to tell it but we met
his friend Alexander who came to say
hello from a nearby Village
she was in the war in Afghanistan too he
told us that he also couldn't stand it
when the Russians came and
um yeah they made their partisan Network
uh they shared information about the
amount of equipment it's movement and
the direction of this movement with our
military
yeah they worked very skillfully on it
we're calling all the time my phone was
taken away
but
I endured because I wasn't afraid of
them and when there is no connection
then how did you call were you looking
for a place to contact and pass
information to the Army we were looking
for it yes we found some points in the
attics and marked places where the
signal was available we were calling and
passing all information we have a son in
Nevada he works with the Armed Forces of
Ukraine uh he calls and says Dad I know
everything dad the soldiers know
everything he said son there is one
thing there is another Sun there are
airplanes there are helicopters dad the
Army knows everything
fantastic people and the way they talked
about it I mean like it sounds for them
even though it was very dangerous but I
mean they're just they're just fantastic
people I can't find the words like in
short they're real ukrainians real
Warriors it doesn't matter how old they
are but these people defended their land
and like no Russian World no they
couldn't stay here with such people
I mean we will do everything to tell all
these stories to our future Generations
so that no one is gonna forget them
because I mean like everyone needs to
know them
and there was no opinion that the South
was surrendered or something else like
in any way people defended themselves
they defended their land and so like
little by little we'll liberate all of
our territories and we'll be reigning in
our land
so um
yeah we're grateful to these fantastic
people so our military forces and to our
soldiers and things to whom we managed
to reach and communicate with these
people while their emotions were still
um very fresh
the way they talked about how they
celebrated how they cried is well it's
worth a lot
you understand how valuable each Victory
is for each of us we'll all celebrate
the victory of Ukraine the final one I
can't even imagine how big it will be
but it will be a huge celebration I like
the road
it's a typical thing for the deoccupied
territories when you drive and
everywhere you see signs that there are
minds and burnt equipment in it is
everywhere
we spent three and a half hours on the
road right around that time and in The
Villages
there is civilian vehicles
and destroyed cars and a lot of
equipment in the fields
in one place we saw dead cows in the
field so it's typical for deoccupied
territories
foreign
it still shocks you constantly
because in normal life you wouldn't be
able to imagine it
when you drive through territories where
everything is mined and shelled
territory
even six months ago
you couldn't have imagined that there
would be such
scale
and speaking of the fact that a year ago
we were talking with people from Odessa
about the last Expedition through
bessarabia
when we visited Odessa
the man said that he was from Odessa and
I immediately remembered this trip how
cool it was how beautiful it was
we went to shoot some nature reserves
interesting people and now we are
filming the war and destroyed villages
that destroyed many lives destroyed
families destroyed everything that
people had amassed yeah but we're
filming cool and interesting partisans
yes but it's cool that we're filming
it in the liberated territories
and that means that we will rebuild all
of this there will be new cows new cars
New Roads and this is a cool incentive
for us to live on and rebuild everything
but returning from the village of
chikalava region
there is
only one rolled to this Village because
the others
have not been demanded
and this road is simply covered with
flex that warn about mines everywhere
along those sites so you need to be very
careful not to turn anywhere and one of
the dangers that I see when there is a
swamp
it's important not to get thrown off
there are two hours of tough road ahead
we drive in the afternoon with such I'll
be honest a risky feeling and in many
moments where we simply moved through
this mud closely
I hope that we will return home happily
and now wait for a car to pull us out of
here
the work that we do is very important
for us for people and for Ukraine
yeah also since we have a large foreign
audience
is important for boosting support for
Ukraine abroad
promote Ukrainian content
do not forget that there is an
opportunity if you have already donated
to the Army to remember that there is
our patreon
we will be very grateful if you also
want to help us and continue our series
of deoccupation stories about heroes
today was a Ultra long and difficult
Road and totally by chance we managed to
find people with whom you can go and
film some stories in an area where no
one has been yet
it's very important for us because these
people have been alone for a long time
and the opinion about them is often
distorted for us this is a very
important trip because to put it bluntly
we do not give up
if you don't have anything to film we
continue to look for people who can talk
to us and we appeal to all the military
and we thank those people who support us
here in the organization of our
Expeditions and in helping us with
getting around the deoccupied
territories
and uh even though normalization
measures have just been completed very
recently we have the opportunity to tell
our audience the stories of people from
the from the occupied territories
glory to the Armed Forces we'll see you
[Music]
thank you